اليوم المملكه تستهدف انها تكون حسب
الرؤيا اقل من ثمان وفيات نكون 100,000
سنه في 2030
انا متفائل ربما نصل الى يعني اذا الجهود
بهذا الرتم وبهذا الزخم ربما نحقق لكن ترى
على فكره السلوك المروري كمشهد ما تغير
عندنا في المملكه اليوم في تصور عن كثيرين
انه الاداره العامه المرور صارت الاداره
عامه للكاميرات اكثر من انها اداره المرور
فقط كاميرات تزرع وغرامات همم تنشر
ويعوض على هذا الامر بانه هو اللي يحل
السلامه
ما في كاميرا حتى تصرف باكثر تصرفات رعونا
ثاني وشفنا شوارع اليوم صارت يعني غابات
صراحه في في ذوق همم العام وفي طريقه
القياده هو شو رايك في دور المرور في
موضوع السلامه المروريه في الفتره الماضيه
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه والنعم والجريس
يستضيف قاعده التحول وقاده الاعمال وقاده
رايحه مع المستجدات مستجدات رؤيه السعوديه
20 30
هو المهندس علي الغامدي رئيس المركز
الوطني لسلامه الطرق موضوع مؤلم صراحه
ومحزن جدا وضع السعوديه مع وفيات حوادث
الطرق في وقت اطلاق رؤيا كانت الوفيات
تقارب 11000
سنويا بتوفون بسبب حوادث الطرق غير عشرات
الالاف من الاصابات غير همم
30% من منطقه الصحيه معطله بسبب حوادث
الطرق همم اطراف كثيره ومشتركه في علاج
هذا التحدي اللي كان احد المستهدفات رؤيه
السعوديه 2030 همم
المركز الوطني لذلك في بدايه كلمني عن
المشهد في الماضي همم
بعدين دخلنا على الحدود
عمل يقوم بهذا المركز تكلمني شويه عن
المنظومه الفرق بينهم وبين اللهجه السلامه
المروريه وزاره النقل همم هيئه الطرق
الجديده وبعدين تكلمنا اكثر عن المركز
وايش يسوي يتكلمنا عنصه منصه البيانات
وتكلمنا على نموذج مثلا طريق الرين بيشه
المركز شفت في المنصه هذا الطريق واسمع
لرسائل الناس اللي اكرمونا برسالهم
استفسارات يعني هذا الطريق تحديدا
فاستفسرنا عنا وحدثنا ضيفنا عن همم عن هذا
الطريق وكيف همم الحاله الخاصه فيه وايش
اسبابها بدي اتكلم على المختبر همم اللي
يعمل على التحليل والتحقيق الحوادث
الجسيمه او طلب مثال بنوع من السيارات همم
اللي اكتشفوا انها تؤدي الى وفيات وحوادث
متكرره بيرتب او نمط معين همم فرفعوا
توصيه بايقاف بيع هذه السياره همم تكلم
على عده امثله لك كيف يمكن معالجه او
تخفيف اثر الحوادث حتى لو كانت بخطا من
الشخص كان الشخص اخطا لا يعني ان نتمناه
يموت كيف ممكن الطرق تكون رحيمه وتخفف من
اثر وخطوره الحوادث
لضبط التوقعات الحلقه هذه لا تتكلم عن
جوده الطرق لان هذا الجهاز ليس مسؤول عن
جوده الطرق انا عارف هذا الموضوع يهمنا
كلنا بس هذا الجهاز ليس مسؤول عن جوده
الطرق وهذا الجهاز ليس مسؤول عن الزحمه في
ايضا اللي متوقع اننا نتكلم عن الزحمه ما
تكلمنا عنها لانهم ليسوا مسؤول عن ذلك لكن
تكلمني عن المرور ودوره وكيف انه حسب
رسائل جاءتنا منكم في عتب على غياب المرور
من ممارسه دوره اكثر من مجرد نشر
الكاميرات ورصه المخالفات عن طريق
الكاميرات همم طرحنا مجموعه من اسئلتكم
الثمينه همم اللي اكرمتنا فيها فهمم
اترككم مع الحوار حياك الله ابو عبد الله
شرفتونا نورتنا الله يسلمك تشرفنا بك يا
اخ عمر ان شاء الله تكون يعني لقاء ان شاء
الله مميز مفيد ان شاء الله
زرعت في مزرعتك
قالولي انك وايد زراعه الاسنان
الصيف يعني والاهل حي الزيتون انا محب
اشجار الزيتون كل منطقه يعني ما شاء الله
هي اصلا منطقه يعني يطلع فيها الزيتون
البري
بالجوف هي اللي اشتهرت
كبيره لكن الباحه يعني هو من النبات اللي
يعتبر يعني بري في الباحه الزيتون وفيه
يعني اصبح الان يمكن اكثر من 30 نوع جربت
في منطقه الباحه من كافه اللي تزرع فيها
الزيتون يعني طبعا الجوف استفدنا من
التجربه
وانا عندي في البيت مجموعه حقيقه نعصر
منها بس المشكله 25 كيلو لي طلع منها رجال
وصغير كده ههه يعني لكنه جميل
طبعا بحسب الكميه يعني بس انا ما عندي الا
كميه يعني يمكن 30 او 40
لازم تكون منطقه بارده جدا عشان يثمر
الزيتون او يعني على الاقل موسم من السنه
همم يعني لازم لها اجواء معينه ما تنبت في
يعني وبالتالي المنطقه البارده ما في شك
انه يعني تعطي يعني ثمر افضل لكنه في
انواع تعرف كثير يعني فيها اليوناني فيها
همم
طبعا عندنا ما شاء الله يعني تجربه كبيره
يعني
الحمد لله من المملكه يعني اليوم
لكن اللي الشجره اللي انا اعتز يعني شوي
اااه واحد
الزملاء واصدقاء من نفس قريتي همم اهداني
شجره
ال ال اللبانه العماني
فجاب شجر منك واهداني
فكانت جميله مميزه لانه نادر يعني
زرعتها وزرعتها وان شاء الله يعني شكله
بوادرها طيبه ولا خبر قد شفت فيديو كيف
همم
تجرح الشجره
نعم
الان في ما شاء الله يعني ابناء المنطقه
مع الجمعيات الزراعيه مع الدعم التي تقدمه
الدوله يعني تشجيع الزراعي المزارعين
اصبحوا يجيبوه نبتات ما كانت موجوده
همم
[موسيقى]
يعني ايضا اعتقد انه حتى من الاهداف
الزراعيه المنطقه بجانب الزيتون اللي هو
همم
كذلك الموز في يعني في تهامه غامضه
موجود الموز والمانجو بكميات كبيره اشترى
لي زرتنا في الصيف
عندكم ان شاء الله
الخطوط امنه والله في المملكه كامله ههه
احنا
سعداءتك بصفتك رئيس المركز الوطني لسلامه
الطرق همم واللي هو يعني
جزء من المنظومه ومهمه جدا
تتولى ملف حساس ومؤلم ومحزن صراحه المشهد
اللي واقع فيهم عده زوايا يعني انا بختبس
من محاضره العقيد الدكتور زهير عبد الرحمن
شرف مدير الانظمه واللوائح في مرور منطقه
المدينه المنوره عام 2013 كان عنده محاضره
نعم يقول في السعوديه تحت المركز الاول
عالميا في حوادث الطرق هذا الكلام 2013
الف انسان توفوا
في العقدين اللي تسبق 2013 احنا بنتكلم
على التسعينات ولا الفئه الاولى 86,000
انسان يعني هنتكلم على وفيات تفوق حروب
الهند وباكستان تفوق
حروب استقلال كرواتيا احنا نتكلم على حرب
حقيقه الحرب يعني اكثر من الوفيات الارهاب
اللي صارت في السعوديه فاحنا عندنا يعني
ازمه حقيقيه ااه موضوع فئه الطرق وعندنا
ازمه من الناحيه الثانيه اللي هي جوده
الطرق من وجهه نظر كثيره
خصوصا داخل المدن همم محزنه ودائما تنعكس
على جوده الحياه على السلام على اشياء
كثيره فاليوم احنا نتكلم على ملف مره
يلامس حياه الناس همم يزعج الكثير يقلق
الكثير خطف ارواح من كل همم اسره احد لازم
يعني الله يبعد عنكم الشر ف ودي اول شيء
بوصف المشهد ال- ال- ال- الالم اللي موجود
في هذا الملف
الحقيقه مثل ما تفضلت يعني هذا
الجانب هذا يعني مؤلم بكل ما تعنيه الكلمه
في العقدين اللي تفضلت فيهم سواء
التسعينات او الالفيه انا اعتقد حتى
الارقام يمكن اقل من ما هو حقيقي ما قالوا
في انا ذاك الوفيات المروريه كانت معظمها
تحسب لمن يموت في موقع الحادث
في المستشفى مثلا فتره ويموت لا يحسب قد
لا يحسب كثير منها لا تحسب تعتبر يعني
هذا كان في الماضي
الحقيقه انه كانت فعلا المملكه يعني لا
تستحق ان تكون في مكانه
متدنيه في السلامه المروريه يعني في في
ذاك تلك الفتره وانا اذكر كنت اتحدث وزملا
يعني لما تيجي تشوف اسباب الوفيات في حتى
الدول اللي سبقتنا في السلامه في اوروبا
في امريكا في استراليا في دول الشرق
الاسيوي الصناعيه تجد انه
يعني وجود السائق تحت يعني في ظرف او يعني
مسكر او في يعني بعيد عن الوعي هو السبب
الرئيسي للوفيات طيب احنا بلد مسلم ما هو
متاح هذا الشيء
ليش نكون يعني لما تاخذها كاف مقارنه يعني
او كذا الشيء الاخر انا ذاك كان نص السكان
يعني لا يتاهلوا القياده المراه
فبالتالي كان الرقم كبير كبير اذا بدات
تحسد بالنسب حتى كان 100 يعني اللي عندنا
الوفيات اللي 100,000 نسمه غير عادل في
المقارنه لانك استبعد ايضا النصف الاخر
مجتمع عندنا في المملكه دبل تقريبا
[موسيقى]
ولكن خلينا نقول انه يعني عدم وجود المسكر
اللي هو سبب رئيس في الوفيات في في الدول
الصناعيه وعدم ايضا يعني تغيب نصف المجتمع
عن جهه السياره ما كان يجب ان نقوم بهذا
المستوى الحقيقه ما اعطى صوره جيده على
المملكه يعني في سنوات همم للاسف انه
الاشكاليه الحادث عندما يقع هناك اثار
كبيره له
خلينا نترك الاثار المعنويه اللي هي اكبر
وقع على الانسان يعني عندما يموت يعني من
تحب في حادث مروري وابن ابنه اخ اخت او
حتى والده وام شوف كيف الاثر على الاسر
وقد اسر هناك تنجر الى الانحراف بسبب ان
رب الاسره او ربه الاسره يعني ذهبت في
حادث ولا احد يعولها بالشكل المناسب
بالاضافه يعني للجانب المعنوي الجانب مادي
خساره كبيره الناس تعتقد انه الحادث يصير
وقضاء وقدر وانتهى الموضوع احنا كلنا نؤمن
بالقضاء والقدر ولكن نعرف من ديننا ايضا
يعقلها وتوكل
الخسائر اللي تقع في الحادث لما نيجي نشوف
الخسائر هذه خصوصا التي تؤثر على التنميه
بشكل عام على مستوى الاسره على مستوى ال
ال ال البلد بشكل عام اولا اااه هناك
انفاق اداري
يعني كبير على كل حادث معقول اليوم سياره
المرور رجل المرور عندما يتحرك من مكتبه
الى موقع الحادث هل يتحرك سياره ويقطع جزء
من ساعات العمل من اجل حادث يعني يمكن
متوسط ما يقضيه همم يعني رجل المرور مثلا
في تحقيق في الحادث الوفيات يعني بعطي رقم
مقارب حقيقه من 2018 او شيء حوالي 22 ساعه
تخيل انه كله يقضيه تاكل
جزء من راتبه على هذا الحادث ايضا همم
الاسعاف والنقل الاسعاف ايضا اغلاق الطريق
وربما هناك خسائر في الممتلكات العامه
بالاضافه الخاصه هناك ايضا
طوارئ في المستشفى يعني السرير يشغل
بمريض الحادث او مصعب الحادث بدلا من
المريض الذي قد يحتاج المستشفى لمرض هادي
عندك نسبه لعدد الاسره او نسبه الاسره
للمشغوله بحوادث مرور الناعم هناك دراسه
فيها يعني في السابق وربع ما زالت عن نفس
الارقام انه ثلث اسره المستشفيات في
المملكه تشتغل بالمصابي الحوادث
يعني اذا الدوله تخصص ميزانيه الصحه في
اختطاع منها الثلث فقط فقط
يعني ضحايا الحوادث وتخفيف الامامهم
اليوم يمكن
السرير الواحد يعني انا بعطي ارقام متوسطه
يعني ليست في مستشفيات حكوميه يكلف الدول
من 400 الى 500,000 سرير الواحد
تخيل عندما يكون عندك ثلث اسئله
المستشفيات لي مصابين حوادث واثر هذا على
تقديم الخدمه لمن يحتاج المستشفيات نتيجه
امراض لانه اذا شغلت المستشفيات بهذا الكم
الكبير من ال ال ال ال المصابين الحوادث
بكل تاكيد ان يكون هذا الحساب المرضى
اخرين يعني وهذا ايضا يزود الفاتوره على
الصحه وعلى الدوله وعلى الاعداء لكن هناك
ايضا جانب اخر
رب العمل اليوم انت في القطاع الخاص وحتى
القطاع الحكومي عندما يقع مثلا مهندس او
ضابط او حتى شخص موظف يعني في اي اي في
موقع معين
ويكون ضحيه حادث مروري رب العمل يتاثر
والعمل بحاجه ايضا لمن يكون يحدث اعاقه
اعاقه ايضا رب العمل يتاثر
وهناك مراكز تاهيل تعمل من اجل يعني انا
اذكر انه كانت يعني الاعاقات المستديمه
لتخرج من الحوادث السنويا من 2000 الى
3000 معاق
بالاضافه الاسره
تفقد العائل لها تفقد المصدر الدخل لها
شوف كم التاثير الاقتصادي الدفاع المدني
حيرتدخل بمركبات الاطفاء الحريق همم وهناك
ايضا فاتوره الازدحام المروري خصوصا في
تخيل طريق زي طريق الملك فهد او الدائري
الشمالي او طريق الملك سلمان همم وقع في
حادث في في ذروه وهو حادث بسيط
يعني شوف كم الدقيقه تكلف كل واحد
المستخدمين الطريق
والاثار النفسيه اللي تعكسها على الازدحام
على على المشكله فهناك مشاكل تنظر بها من
ابعاد كثيره يعني
[موسيقى]
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
ولذلك لما رؤيه السعوديه 20 30 واطلقت
برامج التنفيذيه كان احد همم اهم مستندات
برنامج التحويل الوطني موضوع السلامه
المروريه ولاحقا نضيف لبرنامج
الصحي ولكن كان الهدف في التحول الوطني
2016 لما اطلق رؤيا ان احنا نبقى نوصل
وقت خط الاساس 28 وفاه لكل مائه الف نسمه
وكان المامون اننا نخفضها الى 23 وفاه لكل
نسمه في 20 20 وتحتها مجموعه مبادرات
ومستهدفات وبرامج احدها المركز نفسه
فالان ودنا ننتقل من هذا المشهد القادم
الى حكايه التحول
نبدا بالمركز نتكلم على منظومه مين اللي
اليوم يعملون على مكافحه هذه الافه نعم
انا خليني انطلق من
كلمه ذكر الامير محمد بن سلمان اسمه ولي
العهد الله يحفظه الحقيقه في اعلان خلينا
بعد التحول يعني في جانوري 20 21 عندما
اعلن عن دراعين
ذكرت فلسطين انت مهمه جدا حقيقي واخذها
العالم بها اهميه
يعني ذكر
بالنص انه لا يجب ان يكون هناك مليون
انسان
يموت بسبب حوادث المرور سنويه بسبب الحواف
المروريه لان العالم تعرف يموت فيه حوالي
1,000,000 سنويه هذه الرساله اعتراها يعني
لها مضامين كثيره تنظر لها طبعا سمو
الامير همم يعني ربما هو يعني دلائل بس
يكون بيئه مختلفه
وبيئه يعني التنقل فيها امن الى حد ولن
نخسر احد فهي الرساله للعالم انه يجب ان
يغير ولكن هذه الزيتمنت هي نشات من بدايه
التحول في 2016 كان هم من القياده لانه
لابد انه نواجه
الحقيقه خليني انا اقول لك المشهد المروري
في المملكه من ثلاثه عقود حتى الان تخصص
عندما تنظر الاحصائيات في النقل والمرور
عندما تشاهد في الاحصائيات حتى عام 2016
والكلام هذا ايه واحد يقدر يطلع عليه من
مكتبات او من يعني حتى من النت تشوف انه
الاتجاه تصاعدي للوفيات المروريه
يعني وصلنا الى تسعه الاف
وفاه سنويا وبعض
يعني الجهات تقول انها 11,000 او 10 الاف
و900 وكسر في 2017
ولكن كان جهه تصاعدي يعني لم احد يستطيع
ان يكبح جماع هذا الداء
وهذا يعني مشاهد وتستطيع ان اي جراف
احصائي بتحصل فيها الترند هذا المتساعد
بشكل كبير
لمن جاء 2016 وانا اذكر في
عندما يعني كانت تحول الوطني في ابريل
2016 بدايه فكره التحول وبرنامج التحول
وجمعه الجهات الحكوميه واعطونا يعني
مقترحاتكم ولكن اعطونا مبادرات نوعيه لانك
اذا انت عندك مشاريع عاديه
في 2015 لكن كان في ابريل اعلان الرؤيه
صحيح صحيح
همم وكنت يعني من اللي حضيت انا بالمشاركه
مع يعني مع الزملاء
جاء الملف هذا وطلب من الجهات ان تقدم
مبادرات نوعيه يعني اذا كانت تبغى تنشر
طريق او تبري مدرسه ترى هذه ما هو مشروع
نوعي هذا الدوله لا اعطيني مشروع نوعي يحل
مشاكل تثبتها انت ويحتاجها المجتمع وزاره
النقل انا ذاك قدمت يعني ضمن مبادراتها
همم مشروع المركز الوطني لسلامه الطرق تحت
مبادره تقليل الحوادث وفيات حوادث السير
هي مبادره
فكان هذا المشروع
وعندما اطلقت او على يعني وطلقت الرؤيه في
جون 2016 همم وقتها بدات الوزاره في
التخطيط لك كيف طيب الان الحمد لله جاءت
الموافقه الدوله دعمت الان رؤيه تدعم هذا
المشروع لنبدا
فكلفت وزملاء ان يعني ان نبدا تاسيس هذا
المركز ولله الحمد الان اصبح هو واقع واا
خليني اقول لك يعني
في الماضي يعني انا مثل ما ذكرته لك انه
انا يعني بضع يعني مشهد استلام المروريه
ما قبل 2016 وما بعدها
في اهتمام ولكنه لم يكون فعال
وكان يعتمد على ما تقوم به الجهاد لكن
كانت الجهاد تعمل بمازل غالبا يعني في
تنسيق ولكنه كان ضعيف جدا
البهجه 2016 وبدا من 2017 مع مع مبادرات
الرؤيا التفكير اختلف الفلسفه او الذهنيه
اختلفت انه اولا لا يجب ان نعمل بمعزل عن
الاخر
لازم ان يتكامل العمل ومشكله السلامه
المروريه لو انها سهله ما كان وصلنا لحد
يعني في السنوات الماضيه مشكله معقده
تتطلب الجميع المشاركه من الجميع يعني لا
يمكن تيجي تقول لي والله وزاره النقل
البلديات تملك الطرق هي مسؤوله لوحدها ولا
تقدر تفصلها عن اهميه دور وزاره الداخليه
دور كبير
او مثلا الهلال الاحمر والمستشفيات لانه
كله عمل تكامل ايضا نهايه المواصفات
والمقاييس ساسو وهيئات النقل وخلافه
فاللي تغير مع الرؤيه هو
حوكمه العلاقه بين الجهه وكيف هذا نوصفها
بطريقه مبسطه بعيدا عن المصطلح خليني اقول
لك انشاء مركز وطني لسلامه الطرق اليوم
يخدم الجهات كلها ويقدم لها فني المركز
ايش دورها المركز طيب تسمح لي اتكلم على
المشهد يعني اذا اذا حتى يكون فيه ترابط
يعني المركز هو هذا ذكرته انه التحول اتى
يعني في المشهد السلامه المروريه من بعد
2016 كان المركز
بعد المركز يعني اعتماد اعتماده في جون
2016 كانوا بعده بحوالي سنه في جوناي 2017
ان شاء اللجنه الوزاريه للسلام المروريه
احنا لا نقفل مركز
الوزاره
قبل خمس شهور كل هذا نتيجه هذا العراق
اليوم المركز الوطني سلامه النقل ايضا
يعني اعلن عنه قبل حوالي شهر اذا المملكه
اخذت هذا موضوع بفلسفه جديده بعمل تكاملي
لذلك انشات اللجنه الوزاريه لسلامه المرور
السلام المروريه لتقوم بالعمل التنسيقي
يعني حكمه الموضوع انه لما نجلس الجميع
على طاعه ولا واحده احد يحتاج تنسيق مع
بعض وفي لجنه وزاريه وفي لجنه تنفيذيه تحت
اللجنه الوزاريه الجميله
النقل وزير الصحه وزير الصحه نعم اكبر
جهاز
يعني هو الذي يستقبل الضحك في النهايه
وممثله في الداخليه في النقل في البلديات
اعضاء كلهم اعضاء هيئه المواصفات
المركز الوطني
له يعني يشرف عليه وزير النقل بحكم التخصص
الجانب الفني في الموضوع لانه اليوم
المركز الوطني الان ياتي تسمح للمركز
الوطني وتعريفه المركز الوطني كان له اطار
وفق عليه ضمن برنامج التحول الوطني انت
تعرف رؤيه المملكه لها سته اهداف عامه 27
هدف مستوى ثاني واهداف استراتيجيه 96 اصبح
الان احنا الاهداف الاستراتيجيه في الرؤيه
تعزيز السلامه المروري
يعني لاحظ وهذا لم يكن في السابق موجود
اذا انت وضعتها الان كهدف استراتيجي
المركز الوطني
كانوا ايسكو معين واحد
ان يبني منصه للمعلومات والبيانات بحيث ان
هو يكون بيت خبره يعني ومحلل لهذه
البيانات وينظر بها بنظره مختلفه عن
الجهات تعرف الجهات الحكوميه
دائما يعني لديها مسؤوليات كثيره هذا يركز
على جانب السلامه وبالتالي يستطيع ان ينظر
لهذه المناصه بطريقه مختلفه الشيء الاخر
ان يرفع من القدرات البشريه اللي تعمل
لانه اليوم مهما عملت جبتها الاجهزه
والبرامج والمستشارين اذا ما تبن شباب
وبنات الوطن
هذا الجانب بكفاءه عاليه ما تستطيع
الشيء الثالث ان ان يقوم بدور توعوي
وتثقيفه وتدريبي وخلاف وبالتالي اطلقنا
تحت هذا المشروع
عده مشاريع حتى نصل الى تحقيق هدف
عندنا مشروع المنصه
منصه البيانات منصه البيانات
المرصد البيانات حقيقه تتميز يعني عن
قواعد البيانات الاخرى انها مرسيدس او
متنوعه المصادر يعني اليوم يعني الهدف
منها يعني احنا مازلنا الان في المرحله
الاخيره من تطويرها وننسخ مع الجهات
الحصول على البيانات ما زلنا في هذه
المرحله الاخيره ولكن الهدف ان يكون
معلومات الطرق
ولما يقول معلومات الطرق من خرائط الطرق
ومن تصاميم الهندسيه من الادوار لها من
عدد المساراتها واخلافه من حجم الحركه
المروريه عليها وتصنيف الحركه شاحنات او
سيارات صغيره وخلافه هذا واحد جانب الطرق
طبعا جانب الطرق تشرف الان عليها الهيئه
العامه للطرق واللي كان وزاره النقل
والبلديات يعني في السعاده الجانب الاخر
حوادث المرور
حوادث المرور تحت وزاره الداخليه
الزملاء في الاداره العامه المرور والامن
الطرق والجهات الامنيه يقوم بجهه جبار
يعني هم من يحقق في الحادث من ناحيه
المسؤوليه القانونيه وبالتالي هم من يجمع
بيانات الحادث
فيعني يعني نعمل ان يكون ايضا لدينا يعني
حواء خصوصا الحوادث اللي احنا نحقق فيها
اللي هي جسيمه ايضا البيانات الهلال
الاحمر والبيانات الطبيه اليوم المصاب الى
دخل المستشفى في تعريف سكين او مقياس من
منظمه الصحه العالميه يعني الحمد لله ترى
القطاع الصحي عندنا قطاع متطور في المملكه
ويستخدم نفس
المقياس من حوالي 36 انت بتصنيف للاصابات
المروريه
وبالتالي هنحاول ناخذ المعلومات هذه تكون
بالمنصه بالاضافه الى معلومات الهلال
الاحمر لان يهمني متى تحركت سياره الاسعاف
متى وصل استجابه الحادث ومتى وصل ونقل ال
ال المصاب الى المستشفى بالاضافه معلومات
عن المركبات والسيارات وفي هيئه التقييم
حوادث
المرور يعني
نحصل عليها البيانات كم تكلفه يعني
بالمتوسط الحادثه المروري من ناحيه الصدمه
المركبه انا عندي اسئله كثيره عن المنصه
وحنجيها بس بس ابو عبد الله قبل ما نكمل
في المبادرات ارجع ارخص وارتب همم مفهوم
المركز همم لان المركز مو واضحه علاقته
بالجنه والسلام المروريه مو واضحه علاقته
بالوزاره صحيح صحيح انتم كيان مستقل ولا
المركز الوطني
هو مبادره وزاره النقل وبالتالي هو مرتبطه
وزاره النقل
الوزاره وزاره النقل واللجنه وش علاقتكم
فيها اللجنه
مكملين لها بمعنى اللجنه تقوم بالدور
التنسيقي ودعم للجهات سواء دعم ترى مو شرط
الدعم المالي وبس يعني اليوم الجهات اذا
عندها مبادرات نوعيه تقدمها من خلال
اللجنه وترفعها للمسجد الشروق السعوديه
وبالتالي تاخذ مجرى للدعمها لكن الدعم
الاهم انا اشوفه الدعم التشريعي والتنظيمي
يعني انت ممكن تغير تشريع الان هذا من
خلال الاجهزه من خلال اللجنه الوزاريه
وهذا مو شيء انتم احنا نقدم دعم فنيه
الدعم الفني اليوم كبير يعني يعطيك مثال
احيانا مثلا همم الجهه المالكه في الطريق
والمشغل الطريق تقول والله عندي هذا
المشكله الموقع هذا فيه حوادث
احنا نطلع بفريق ممكن نفحص الموقع ونقدم
الحلول
ممكن ما ننتظر لا في طريق صمم لكن في
شكاوي من الناس ممكن يعني يطلب منها اننا
نطلع الطريق ونعمل لهم مسح همم اليوم همم
ترقيق تدقيقات التصاميم المروريه يعني في
السابق الجهات تتعاقد مع مكاتب استشاريه
عشان تقوم بالعملها هذا احنا نقول لهم لا
احنا نسويه لكم
البيانات وتحليلها نقدم المواقع الخطره
بورا الحوادث فينها وبرضو المركز وهذا مهم
جدا انه الخبره في المركز لمن يعني يدرسون
ال- ال- ال- البيانات ويستقرؤونها بطرق
علميه يخرجون عاده بتوصيات لمواقع لم تقع
في الحوادث بعد كجانب السباقي
وهذا مهم جميل يعني احنا بنجي الامثله
يعني خلينا ندخل الان على همم الخدمات
والبرامج اللي ينفذها المركز واحنا منها
لمجله المركز الشباب
شابو البنات هناك على المنصه شفت قدامي
خريطه المملكه وفيها نقط حمراء خضراء وكل
نقطه لما نضغط عليها يبان تاريخ الحوادث
اللي موجوده فيها فانا هنا عندي ملاحظه
وعندي سؤال الملاحظه الله يسلمك اني ما
وجدت الا بيانات وزاره النقل فقط صحيح
حوادث اللي تحدث داخل المدن ما هي موجوده
الحوادث المباشرها امن الطرق ما هي موجوده
فهذا اظن انه يعني خلل نقص في البيانات
لانك ما تقدر تشوف المشهد كاملا الا بوجود
كلها المدخلات فهذا ملاحظه واستفسار
والحاجه الثانيه
عرفنا اننا ال ال الطريق هذا طريق الرين
مليان حوادث ما الذي يحدث بعدها من جانبكم
صحيحا ملاحظتك اخ عمر يعني انه بالفعل همم
مثل ما ذكرت انه هي احنا في نهايه مرحله
تطوير الملز لم نحصل على البيانات كامله
هناك الان تنسيق مع الجهات وزاره الشؤون
البلديه والقرويه للحصول على البيانات
ايضا كما حصلنا من وزاره النقل احنا ليش
وزاره النقل احنا بدانا
يعني لا ننتظر البيانات حتى تاتي البيانات
تعرف يعني اولا ليست على فورمات واحده او
على يعني نظام واحد في كل الجهات يعني
الرابط مع الجهاز عمليه تقنيه همم يعني
همم
تاخذ وقت ما هي يعني هي المشكله تقريبا ما
هي مشكله يعني نقول في الحوكه من بعض
الجهات ما هي متحمسه تشارك معلوماتها معكم
في تعاون كبير بين الجهات والجهات على
السعدات ولكن كل جهه ايضا يعني هي مالكه
للبيانات لابد ان تجلس معها وتعمل حوكمه
معينه كيف تاخذ بياناتها يعني فمن حق كل
جهه يا سواء وزاره النقل او او او مثلا
المرور او الهلال الاحمر والصحه تكتب
البيانات عندكم
مشلوله بوجود جزء صغير نعم انا اعتقد طبعا
يعني والله اتمنى انه خلال عام
انه يعني ننسق بين الجهاز لانه شف ابو عبد
الرحمن يعني مساله اليوم اني اروح واربط
بيانات اليوم اليوم فيه مو عمليه سهله ترى
يعني تقنيه في امن سبراني في فورمات لازم
تكون متوافقه في بيانات انت ما تحتاجها من
الجهه لازم تحدد في مراحل انا اعتقد انه
يعني انا اقول لك يكون عندنا بوادر يعني
سنه من الان قد يكون عندنا بوادر هو
المتبقي تاخذ البيانات من المرور ومن
البلديه ومن البلديات نعم ومن الهلال
الاحمر ومن الهلال الاحمر الان بدانا في
التجربه احنا يعني على فكره احمر همم
طبعا نتمنى انه احنا برضه يعني التامين
ندخل معهم من خلال البنك المركزي لانه
معلومات التامين يكون فيه ربط في بعض
الجوانب لها هذه البنات كلها صارت عندي
كلام
وايش الفائده عندك اليوم انا جبت وزاره
النقل كمثال لمن ربطت مع وزاره النقل
وجدنا على طريق الرين بيشه يعني
هو الطريق
عليه ضغط كبير من الشاحنات يعني اقدر اقول
لكن هو من اكثر الطرق اللي عليها نسبه
شاحنات في الحركه المروريه تصل الى 35%
وهذه وهو طريق مفرد كلمه تقول 35 اكثر
يعني من ثلث الحركه يعني كلها شاحنات
وطريق مفرد مزعج للناس في التجاوز كثير
ومع التجاوز يصير حوادث مع الاسف يعني
امامي وعربا اذا كان لا قدر الله يعني
وقعت في حادث وانت تسير باكثر من 70 كيلو
متر في الساعه علميا
فعالبا اما تخرج بوفاته باصابات خطيره
اتخيل سيارتين تقابلان بسرعه 120 ولا يعني
فوق ال1 تخيل كيف اثبته فطبيعه الطريق
فهذا الشاشه او المنصه اظهرت لكم غير كلام
الناس اظهرت لكم عدد الحوادث
المنصه والمحللين والخبر الموجودين انه
لاحظوا نحن طبعا نتكلم عن فقط ثلاث وفيات
فما اعلى من الحوادث هذه اللي احنا الان
ربما يعني في المستقبل يعني الاستعف يكبر
وكذا ان شاء الله يعني ممكن نغطي ونساعد
الجهاد في اكثر اذا رغبه همم وجدنا انه
مقطع يمكن من 35 كيلو متر تتراكم في
الحوادث
يعني على بعد يعني يعني بعد الرياض يعني
في الجزء القريب من الرياض من جهه الرياض
لو تعرف طريقه شيء يعني ثلاث مناطق يعني
الرياض مكه عسير يعني يعني يدخل في في
ثلاث مناطق لما رحنا وزاره النقل مع طرق
استجابت بشكل عاجل مع امن الطرق حقيقه
للزملاء في امن الطرق يعني يقومون موجود
كبير بالمناسبه يعني وزاره النقل على لانه
تعرف عن الطرق وهو متولي الطرق بين المدن
فجهدهم بصراحه مميز وكبير
فلما بلغنا الوزاره تخيل وجدنا انه في اقل
يعني من 18 شهر
يعني يمكن اربع حوادث
توفي فيها يعني ضحايا يمكن حوالي 22 من
ضمنهم 13 رفعت
طبعا هذا عدد كبير يعني احنا في هندسه
المرور اذا في الثلاث سنوات مات وفات
واحده نعمل له ولد فلاج الموقع
حقيقه مشكوره يعني كانت اصلا تعمل في
ازدواجيه الطريق وفي هذا المقطع كان تحت
الكوليستراكشن ولكن سرعه الان العمل
بالعكس يعني ان اذكر حتى وكيل الوزاره
ومسؤول السلامه ومسؤول الصيانه المركز
لمناقشه الخبراء والتعرف على يعني بالضبط
ايش المشكله
وفعلا خرجه طوالي بقرار علي يعني الوزير
يعني مهتم بالموضوع هذا يعني
تسريع الازدواجيه في المقطع نعم بدات وانا
اعتقد انه همم انا ما اقدر اقول انسانه
لكن بدا اجراءات تحسين حتى ميت يتكرر
الحوادث حتى يتم فتح الطريق لانه تعرف
الازدواجيه وبعدين انت تجعل من كان موجود
مسار وتبري مسار موازي
فهمم يعني الان في اكثر من 200 كيلو انتهت
والان شاء الله ال 35 انا اعتقد انه من
رمضان ناس بدون اشتروه في المقطع هذا بفرق
كبير همم وهذا مثال على كيف ممكن المنصه
تخدمكم وبعدين اعطيك يعني هنا صراحه يعني
همم ابو عبد الرحمن انه تخيل يعني مو يعني
يعز من الوزاره ايضا عندها نظام ومتابعه
ومسؤوليات كثيره لكن وجود جهه مرجعيه
واحده مختصره كبيت خبره اكيد بيكشف لك
اشكالات
نظري ابو عبد الله لما الشباب شرحوا لي
على الخريطه اه لفت نظري انه اذا غلطان
اكثر منطقتين وفيات في حوادث الطرق لما
نقول الطرق وزاره النقل الاخرى واضحه
بياناتها تقريبا غلطان حايل المدينه
حوادث وزاره النقل لانه
وزاره النقل يعني عندها اكثر من 75,000
كيلو متر بين المدن وتغطيها لكن المشهد
اكبر من تتكلم عن داخل المدن اكثر مناطق
حوادث معلنه رصيد اعتقد انها من اللجنه
الوزاريه للسلام المروريه انه اكثر
الحوادث فيها وفيات مروريه يعني انه كل
100 الف نسمه المناطق عندك همم نجران
ومن ثم الجوف
او تبوك
اكثر معدل وفيات مستحيل لكم لها همم خليني
اقول لك الاصابات
يعطيك صوره
كم طيب مصاب لكل 100,000 سنه في الضحايا
الحوادث تجيكم منطقه المدينه المنوره
بعدين منطقه الباحه بعدين منطقه يعطي
العمر مكه المكرمه بعدين جازان
والحدود الشماليه والحدود الشماليه
والجزائر
يعني شوف كيف الانلاحف جيزان متكرره هنا
وهنا
الاول وفيات الحوادث
طبيعتها ترى
يعني شده الحوادث فيها اكبر يعني ما في
مجال يعني في منطقه بريه ممكن تطلع برا
والله ينقذك
ولذلك الوزاره النقل في الطرق الخارجيه
تهتم كثيرا بسلامه جوانب الطرق يسمونه او
المنطقه الخاليه انه ما يكون في معوقات
انه يكون
الاحجار يعني مناسب لو طلعت السياره ما
تنقلب يعني ممكن يرجع لكن في مناطق جبليه
ما صعب يمكن اللي يسبب شده الحوادث في
شمال المملكه
يعني
في سرعات عاليه اذا حتى سرعات موجوده حتى
في المناطق الثانيه
الطرق المفرده يعني
ويعني عاده وجود طبعا انه ناس تاتي من
خارج الحدود يعني دخول البضائع وكذا وكذا
يعني لا تنسى عندنا المملكه منطقه عبور
بين الخليج وبين الجزء الاول
يخلي المشاوير اطوال وبالتالي سرعات اقوى
اكثر والله
صحيح لكنه همم يعني اليوم انا لما احط
السرعه 100 كيلو متر في الساعه
في مناطق جنوب المملكه
يعني متقاربه بشكل فرصه اصلا
طويله بس لو تتمشى في مناطق شمال المملكه
يعني المدن متباعده صحيحه تزيد فرصه ثانيه
اكتشف الطرق البريه عندنا فيها مشكله ممله
يعني انت تسوق على طريق وانا اسوق وبدك
تسرع تمشي والطرق عندنا بصراحه يعني يعني
نتكلم يعني ما تسافر من المدينه لمدينه
عندنا تعرف في المملكه في الربط
يعني الاولى على مستوى العالم يعني الحمد
لله من كل مناطق المملكه تستطيع ان تصلها
بالسياره وهذا ترى يعني همم يعني عمل ضخم
خلال عقود همم جوده الطرق المملكه تستهدف
يعني انا اتكلم على طرق وزاره النقل ان
تكون السادس في العالم ففي تفاعل اليوم
همم
لكنه تستهدف السادس لانه
يعني في الماضي عانت وزاره النقل كثير
نسوء استخدام الطرق من قبل الشاحنات
الاوزان يعني لو تيجي تشوف الطريقه
الشرقيه تحصل مسار الايمن حفر متحفر وكذا
وكذا
او في بعض الطرق حقيقه اليوم طبعا الدوله
بعد التحول يعني يعني نقلت مهمه يعني
الاوزان الى اعتقد تحكم وزاره الداخليه
يعني لانه تحتاج رقابه اكثر يعني انا
لاحظت انه في بعض مواقع اوزان الشاحنات
كنا نصورها
احنا والزملاء من وزاره النقل
وتحكم وهمم يعني امن الطرق
وفعلا كيف يتهربون من الميزان
كبير في اتجاه لكن هذا يحتاج وقت حتى يطلع
[موسيقى]
وما دام انك تجيب طريق جوده الطرق يعني
الاشياء المحزنه صراحه انه جوده الطرق
عندنا تتراجع على البيانات اللي عندي 2012
كان ترتيب 2012 على مستوى العالم مؤشر هذا
العالمي اخر شيء طالع في الموقع حقهم 2017
ترتيبنا 34 فاحنا نرجع للخلف في جوده
الطرق همم اكيد من زاويتكم انتم شفتوا
اخطاء معينه في تصميم او تنفيذ الطرق يعني
همم تزيد خطر الحوادث يعني الحادث يحدث
لكن طريقه تصميم الطريق اللي يتحول الى
حادث مميت او الى حادث اثقل نعم احنا في
التحقيق طبعا احنا ما لنا علاقه فيه مباشر
احنا سلامه الظروف
سواء
البلديات او وزاره النقل
ويعني بحكم قرب يعني من الجهتين ان عندها
يعني مختبر عن جوده وكذا وكذا طبعا تاخذ
في اعتبارات في المملكه مثل ما ذكرت يعني
انه في اضطراد ازدياد مضطرب
على الطرق 16% تقريبا سنويه وهذا يعني
بيكثف الحركه خصوصا في الطرق الداخليه
داخل مدن طبعا كلما زادت الحركه كلما كان
على الحساب يعني عمر الطريق لكن انا ما
بادخل في هذا مو بشغل يعني اوكي وقد يكون
الزملاء
كالطريق ما لكم علاقه
في سلامه الطريق سلامه الطريق فهو الشيء
الاخطاء اللي تحدث في تصميم الطريق
ويحطوها تؤدي الى الوفيات لان انت برضو
عندكم مختبر ضمن الشيء اللي زارتها في
المركز كان في مختبر
التحقيق الفني فهل يدخل في تحقيق الطرق
وتصاميم
يعني
يمكن التحقيق فني من ضمن المعامل تقوم بها
الوزاره النقل كلفت المركز بان تقوم يعني
بتحقيق فني لانه خلينا اوضح معليش للي
يعني شاهدون حتى يستفيد الجميع انه في
انواع من التحقيق لكن الرئيسيه تحقيق
لتحديد المسؤوليه القانونيه او الولايه
وهذه مسؤوليه وزاره الداخليه من خلال
المرور وامن الطرق والجهات الامنيه فمن من
المسؤول عن الحادث بشغلاتكم هذه عند
الداخليه
لانه يحدد المخطيط الفصل الحقوق عند
الداخليه بالضبط بالضبط
وهذا الهدف يختلف على الهدف الاول لانه
التحذير لتحقيق الفني وتاي هيئه الفريق
تختلف عن
المسؤوليه تمام لكن المهم في التحقيق
الفني
اليوم انا ما احقق فنيا او نسميه تحليل
الاستقصاء يا وكذا المعلومات الحادث انه
ما احقق فنيا
لايجاد السبب فقط
السبب قد يكون استخدام جوال
السعر قد اشتراك جديد يعني او انه ملتهي
بالجوال بشيء ثاني او نعسانه وطلع من
الطريق لكن ممكن يكون ماله ذنب فيه يعني
ضرب الاطار يعني حتى هو الايطالي جديد
ممكن يبنشر عليك
120 فخرجت عن الطريق فالسبب هو الاطار
نفسه او مثلا في حفره في الطريق ما عمل
الصيانه بشكل جيد مالك ذنب فيه وبالتالي
حاول تتفاداها خرجت من الطريق اذا في سبب
انك خرجت من الطريق بسبب الحادث لكن الاهم
عندي شده الحادث
طيب طلعت من الطريق في انحدار قوي مثلا او
غير مطابق المواصفات او في عمود كهرب على
بعد 2 متر من الطريق ما وضع ولا هو محمي
بالتالي صدمت فيه النتيجه كانت شده الحادث
كبيره اذا في فرق بين تربيه الحادث وجده
يعني حتى نحاول اليوم
شكرا على السؤال
همم اليوم
يعني اذكر فيه
الزملاء في المختبر لمده 11 شهر وقع اربعه
حوادث لنوع من انواع المركبات بدون تسميه
مات فيها الله يرحمهم او كانت ضحايا حوالي
21 او 22
يعني كان منهم 14 وفاه ثمانيه مصابيين
هذا النوع من المركبات يعني يقع في ثلاث
مناطق من المملكه على ما اتذكر
ونفس السناريو خروج من الطريق وانقلاب
في نفس السياره بنفس السياره واقطع مكرره
مكرره
المحققين لما جينا درسنا المركبه وجيب لنا
ان فيها خلل تصميمي
نوع هي من نوع المرتفع عن الطريق
في اي خروج طوارئ
طوالي اخذنا اكشن او او قرار من المركز
رفعنا للوزاره وزاره متجاوب حقيقه يعني
يعني اي توصيه من المركز تاخذ باهميه
اولويه
وطوالي يعني خاطب الزملاء في ساسو حقيقي
انا
يعني احب اني يعني يعني اشكر الزملاء
المواصفات والمقاييس السعوديه على دائما
تفاعلهم ما ياتي من المركز حقيقه في هناك
يعني مركز لسلامه المركبات
والان هم يدرسون لانه هذا قريبا الكلام
هذا يدرسون هذا النوع طبعا سيؤخذ في قرار
انها تعدل المواصفات او قد تمنع او قد
يوقف استخدامها او قد ينبه المجتمع انه
انت عندك السياره راجع يعني الوكيل او لا
تستخدمه او تنبه من استخدامها فهذه وحده
من الفوائد يعني كان ممكن يمر مثل الحادث
10 وهو وقفت السياره من العلبه همم
القرار ننتظر من ساسه يعني ياتينا الرد ان
شاء الله وبعدها ربما يعني تبلغ الجمارك
او تبلغ وزاره التجاره اذا رات يعني نهايه
المواصفات المقاييس ان ذلك يستدعي او
مراجعه الوكيل لاصلاح واحده من النقاط
اللي بنتكلم عن المواصفات من الاشياء اللي
اكله لكم مؤخرا الموضوع كود الطرق همم
واللي يمكن ان تذكرت انه في الماضي كانت
الطرق تبنى بانماط مختلفه وموا مختلفه ولا
في شيء يجمعها كود سعودي اليوم لو تحدثنا
عن همم المشكله الموجوده وكيف الكود ممكن
يحلها وش علاقتكم انتم في الكود يعني انت
تعرف انه همم المملكه يعني فيها من اعظم
يعني اكبر شبكات الطرق في العالم يعني
سواء بين المدن او داخل المدن يعني شبكات
ضخمه جدا جدا
ومتنوعه من الجسور والانفاق وطرق سريعه
ومزدوجه ومفرده وبالتالي ضخامه التنميه
التي حدثت في المملكه كان هناك طرق داخل
مدن وخارج المدن
وايضا كان هناك هيئات مثل الهيئه الملكيه
الجويه ينبع عندها مدن الخاصه فيها ارامكو
المطارات ايضا لها مواصفات للطرق يعني
تلاحم دائما حدود المطارات تدخل احيانا
تختلف عليك المواصفات عن خارج كذا ااا
السبب انه ما كان في مرجعيه واحده
للمعايير الهندسيه
فكل جهه
تشتغل بمواصفات هي تعلمت وتدربت عليها قد
تكون امريكيه قد تكون يعني وزاره النقل
يعني كانت ماشيه مع الانستلام امريكي يعني
معروف دليل الهاشم الجهات الاخرى الاش تو
ولكن كان الاستشاري اذا كان اوروبا نقل
خبره الاوروبيه من استراليا جاب موصفاته
الاستراليه وهل مجره
لالالا الوزاره تنبهت لهذا الامر وزاره
النقل يعني يكون انها اول من اصدر يعني هي
مع وزاره البلديات قصروا الادله ومعايير
للتصميم الهندسي
فيعني انه نحتاج الان مرجعيه واحده
فيعني كلفت الوزاره النقل
وتشرفنا نحن بالمركز ان نكلف في هذا
المشروع الكبير حقيقه يعني انا بقول لك
يعني وزاره النقل يعني في السنتين الاخيره
يعني مثل ما ذكر كان استراتيجيه
النقل والخدمات الماجستير السلامه ذكرت
فيها اكثر من 100 مره ذكرت لصلاح العباره
في الاستراتيجيه طلعت توصيه بناء على
التحول الوطني لانشاء المركز بس خلينا
نتكلم ابو عبد الله على الاثار لبلام
لما تصبح واحده
المنظم يسهل في ان تتبنى مواصفات واحد الى
الجميع هذه الاشياء اللي تمنتها وزاره
النقل مشروع الكود همم سيلزم يعني المفترض
ان يصدر الكود كما يعني كود البناء
السعودي همم
نظام يصدر من مجلس الوزراء سيالزم الجميع
الطريقه
من بدء من التخطيط يعني كل حياه الطريق من
تخطيط الطريق كيف يخطط وكيف يدرس وما هي
الدراسات لانه انت الطريق تعرف لما تقول
انا بشي طريق من نقطه عاليه
لابد نعرف التضاريس اتجنب الاوديه اتجنب
مثلا مسار السيول مثلا اتجنب
المناطق اللي فيها اثار او قد تضر منها
مواد الزراعيه وحضاريه معينه هذه المرحله
التخطيط ومن ثم التصميم
ومن بعدها التنفيذ ومن بعده التشغيل
والصيانه كل هذا الكود يتعامل معه يعني
نعم واعتقد ان شاء الله يعني خلال ثلاثه
اشهر
الحقيقه انا اقول لك خليني اقول لك موقف
حصل لي يعني الموقف يعني يقول لك لمن تعمل
مع اناس انا ما ابغى الناس تفهمني غلط لكن
والله انت جبت الشهاده بقوله تسمح لي يعني
في المعايده الحج العام الماضي كنت في
الوزاره معايده وزاره النقل في سلمت على
معالي الوزير يعني من ضمن المعاين يعني
قبل ما يرد عليه بالمعايده قال لي شو
اخبار الكود
واضح انه مستعجلين عليه ومستعجلين عليه
حقيقه ومعاليه يعني رئيس لجنه توجيهي على
فكره وزاره النقل تشرف على المشروع لكنها
لحاله تشتغل فيه اليوم في لجنه
توجيهيه فيها عشر جهات برئاسه مع الاناء
بالوزير الطرق يعني تقوم بمتابعه يعني
المشروع
ثلاثه شهور ان شاء الله
بحول الله تعالى الان احنا في المرحله
الاخيره حقيقه كان الضغط
اللي ضربتهم
والهيئه الملكيه والمطارات هذول مستواهم
جيد همم الى ممتاز وزاره النقل للطرق اللي
بين المدن جيده وفي كثير من الحالات يعني
في ظني انها مقهوره الطرق اللي داخل المدن
هذه الاساسات هذه يعني الدول اقل من همم
وضع بتشهد فيها الطرق من البشاعه والرداء
اللي موجوده في مودنا
شوفنا التصنيف اولا ال- همم ان طرق داخل
المدن هي اسوا طرق عندنا
يعني اليوم في توسع في المدن كبيره
احيانا استعمالات الاراضي لا تتوافق مع
التخطيط العظيم لاسباب مختلفه ما فهمت
شلون يعني اليوم انا انا ممكن ان يتقاطع
ممتاز هنا
بافضل ما يمكن لكن اتفاجا انه والله مشروع
يعني تجاري كبير حول هذا التقاطع
سكان اثر سلبي على الطريقه الحركه عليه
يعني انا الطريقه احيانا على مستوى حركه
معين ولكن نتفاجئ ان استعمالات الاراضي
فعله يعني كانت عاليه
للاحياء ابو عبد الله شارع فجر امطرت
في الاحياء اقل من المامون ونعتقد انه
المفروض الان وزاره البلديات بديها برنامج
يمكن لاحطه في بعض الاحياء عمر انه في
يعني بدات تلتفت لهذا الامر يعني اليوم
اشكاليه يعني تخيل يعني حي سكني تجد في
طريق 40
ترى هذا مو موجود بالعالم
يعني مع المفروض يكون حي سكني احد يدخل حي
الله اهل الحي والساكنين ليس منطقه عبور
اذا تبي تعبر المدينه روح للمحاور
الرئيسيه زي في مدينه الرياض طريق الملك
فهد الملك عبد الملك سلمان
الطرق الرئيسيه اللي تقدر انت همم فاصبحت
مع الاسف في المناطق السكنيه تستخدم
للعموره اكثر من استخدام وهذا يعني سبب
مشاكل الان توسيع الارصفه مشاري
ايوه والان سنه يعني هو مفهوم موجود لكنه
فعل من برامج مبادرات التحول وهذه واحده
من يعني اهميه التحول يعني ومشاريعه انه
اليوم لما تحول
الطرق في احياء سكنيه الى انت ضيقت الطريق
ايش معنى ضيقت الطريق
خففت السرعه هذه
نحن اليوم
مفهوم التهدئه المروريه
الوزاره الان والبلديات وحسب علمي من يعني
قربي منهم مهتمين في هذا الموضوع يعني
وكيف انا انسن هذه بتوسيع الارصفه واتحتها
للناس تمشي
تشجير جميل ممكن تجلس ممكن
الكافيهات عليها وكذا وكذا يخلق جو
اجتماعي جميل وايضا بيئه امنه للتنقل حتى
يروح يصلي بالمسجد الطلاب المدرسه اللي في
الحي يعني هذه بيئه امنه بالاضافه الى انه
بيكون من فين هالتوسيع على حساب الطريق
الذي ذكرته لك انه كان من الخطا يكون
عندنا طرق 40 و30 في داخل الاحياء تقلل
هذا يخف الضغط يعني حتى العابر عليه من
اول اللي كان يجيء الشيخ
ولو ابو عبد الله بنرجع لموضوع المواصفات
عشان اقفل هذه النقطه مش اكثر خطا فني
لاحظتوه في الطرق يزيد الحوادث او يزيد
شده الحوادث ايش اكثر اخطاء فنيه واحد او
اكثر او ثلاثه والله شوف يعني انا اقول لك
بعض الاحيان ما ينفذ الطريق
بالمواصفه كما هي
يكون خلل يكون بعض الاحيان ترى معوقات حتى
خارج هالمركه انا ما ابغى اسويرات
انه دائما يؤدي الى الحوادث جدا طبعا تعرف
لانه راضي ممتلك ويجببر تقسيم الطريق على
يعني الضغط على الطريق وعمل تحذير وهذا
يزعل يعني لما تقول لي انا ماشي 100% تقول
لي انزل له 30 او 40
وياخذها بعض الاحيان لا بمشي بسرعه
المنحنى هذا صعب وهكذا كامل فيه لولا نزعل
الملكيه لكن بعطيك مثال من ذكرت احنا
وجدنا في مدينه الرياض احدى تعرف في
تقاطعات المحولات اللي هي الكباري والجسور
زي ميدان القاهره او ميدان مثلا
الرباط
حصل حادث في احد الميادين
الله يرحمهم توفوا اثنين واثنين مصابين
ساقطه السياره من اعلى الجسر جينا طلبنا
يعني نحقق في هذا الحادث وجدنا انه صراحه
متقادم السياج المعدني
وهناك مواصفات اليوم افضل عندما بنيت
الطريق
الجسر هذا
واعطينا المواصفه بالكامل روحنا للجهه
المالكي الطريق وبدات الان تعمل لكن
الجميل في هذا يعني رغم ماسات الحادث انه
وجدنا انه في الرياض يمكن خمسه ميادين
تستخدم نفس
السياج الاول
الطريق نتابعناها بالمناسبه احنا عندنا
داش بورد
قديش بورد هذا عندنا يعني
الواحد لصالح القرار
الهاي لفل مره
وواحد
اللي يعملون يعني كمودر عموم والذين
يعملون بشكل يومي
نتابع فيه يعني لما انا اعطي توصيل مثلا
لوزاره النقل
عندهم صانع القرار يستطيع ان يشوفها
بالاحمر ليش او صارت بالاخضر
وكل شهر
ونبلغ قديش هذا موجود
يعني يعطيك هذا مثال مثلا سبقنا انه ممكن
المحولات الثانيه والجسور والكبائر الثاني
ممكن يقع فيها نفس الحادث اذا حمايه غير
الان الجهه المالكه بدات تغيير همم يعني
بعضها
في طريق الانتهاء ايضا المهام اللي حطها
ضمن العمل مركز اثناء الجوله موضوع
الاعتماد المهني
وحتى قابلت واحده من الزميلات يبدونها
حصلت على اعتماد يعني همم اول واحده تحصل
عليها في السعوديه او شيء منها القبيل
برامج الاعتماد يتقدمونه
حقيقي يعني
اللي يميز الرؤيه اليوم لا تسالني انا
كمشارك فيه او انني اعرف ما قبل الرؤيه
وما بعد الرؤيه
الشفافيه والمحاسب
بصراحه
اليوم انا عندي مشروع في المركز اداء وراي
ايش سويت
ارفع يعني
ريبورت ربع سنوي في مؤشر
الانجاز
لهذا المشروع
ولو انا مثلا ما انجزت
النايل ستون او المعلم بحسب الخطه يجيني
مركز اعدام من خلال في ار او المكتب
الرؤيه في في وزاره النقل ليش يحاسبك
وقد لا تكون محاسبه يساعدك ممكن تعمل شجره
الشفافيه
والمحاسبه اليوم
يه يعني انا اليوم عشان انا انجز في
المركز في التدريب كان هذا ضمن الموجات
طيب
مؤشرات الاداء عندك انت طيب عندك تدريب بس
مجرد تجيب ناس تجربهم لا اول ما بدانا
المملكه مع التنميه كانت تستخدم مهندسين
كثير
السعوديه مشكله سلامه الطرق ليس تخصص في
الجامعه وتخرج عليه مثلا بكالوريوس
هو ضمن تخصص مدنيه معماريه كان ممكن يكون
مهندس سلامه ولكن ياتي بالتدريب بتراكم
الخبره لك لازم لكن لازم يكون عندك
التراكم المعرفي في الهندسه مثلا
او التدريب الجزء الثاني الجزء الثاني
ما يوجد مهندسين سلامه
محترف بالخبره وبعضهم تقاعد وراح ولكن ما
في يعني مهندسين سلامه ولكن تاهيل ما عنده
غير خبرته حلو وما حد قيمه
ليس تقريبا في الزملاء
لكن هذا كان الواقع ان اول شيء وش البنت
العالميه افضل ممارسه في امريكا
يعني عندهم هناك ما يمارس هندسه سلام
الطرق الا مهندس محترف سلامه من برامج
اعتماد مهني رحنا لهم
كلمنا الزملاء في الهيئه السعودي
المهندسين
رحنا للجهه هذه تناقشنا مع عقل والله احنا
ما عمر امريكا
احنا المملكه العربيه السعوديه واحنا
نحتاج
وكثير من المبتعثين عندكم
بعلاقتنا معهم الحمد لله
اتاحوا لنا لانه لابد يعني يكون موافقات
عليه انه يكون في امتحان او اختبار
للاعتماد المهني في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ويرخص بناء عليه يقول والله هذا
مهندس محترف سلامه الطرق طبعا تعرف في
الاختبارات البرنامج
يكون عندك شهاده من تخصص معين يكون عندك
خبره اللي يحقق هذه
يعني بتخرج اليوم بكره لازم اشتغل حلو
مو بشرط احنا موفرين ترى البرنامج التدريب
اليوم على منصه التدريب في المنطقه في في
المركز يعني ممكن خلال 24 ساعه يتواصل
الكترونيا ويعرف البرنامج ويقرا منه لابد
تشتغل على نفسك شويه بعدين تدخل احنا
عندنا ثلاث اختبارات ثلاث فترات في السنه
في فبراير في جون في اكتوبر
ويختبر طبعا الاختبار من امريكا مو من
عندنا لكن ايش اللي سوينا مع الجهه
الامريكيه الاي تي اي وال بي سي تي في
اين عمل بروفيشنال سرتفيكيشن بروجرام بورد
الامريكي
تجيب اختباره ما حد ينجح
لانه انتم مثلث الاختبار تقريبا او اكثر
من الربع على التشريعات والتنظيمات
الامريكيه
اشتغلنا معهم وضعنا جزء خاص لنا في
المملكه حتى ممكن يستخدم في منطقه الخليج
والمنطقه العربيه وغيره في الجزء هذا بحيث
ان يكون مناسب للتشريعات والتنظيمات في
المملكه
وعملنا اتفاقيه الان لنا طول العمر يمكن
سنتين اااه يمكن 50 او اكثر حتى دخلوا
الاختبار همم تجاوز منه لكن الجميع لانه
10% من ابنها والخليج خصوصا من الامارات
وقطر الان عمان تواصلوا معنا بعض
المهندسين في الاختبار لانه الاختبار هذا
يعطيك مثل السياره
الان مش المشكله كده انت كيف تقدر تستخدمه
الناس اللي في القطاع الان تقول له تعال
اذا ما في الزلزام ليش يجي ياخذ
استنى اختبارات المهنيه من المحببه طبعا
الناس وبالعكس هناك مقاومه ايضا لهذا
التغير بصراحه يعني لكن وجدنا حماس كثير
المهندسين مهندس السعودي ومهندس متميز متى
ما وجدت الاهتمام وضحت للطريق وبنيت لها
المسار المهني ينطلق بكل سهوله وهذه من
تجربتي انا شخصيا ليس ان حيازه للمهندسين
كولي مهندس لكن حتى في المركز عندهم شغف
عندهم حب للتعلم والتدرب اليوم احنا نتعلم
هو طبعا تعرف حدود سنتين او اقل بدانا
الاختبارات صار فيه نسبه نجاح معقوله
البرنامج التدريبي اعطى يعني ثمار بدا دول
الخليج ترتفت يعني
كان عندنا وزير الاشغال البحريني معجب
بهذا البرنامج يعني قبل اسبوعين صار
المركز فا يعني اصبح المركز يعني ناس كثير
بتسال عن هذا يعني انت لما تبدا تمهيد
لازم اول شيء تاسس البرنامج ما تبغى تيجي
اوفر نايت يعني بين يوم وليله تقول يلا من
بكره لازم تاخذ تكون انت مهندس محترف
ولا ما تشتغل في المشروع فهيانا الان
البرنامج جربناه الان ناجح البرنامج
الان احنا نعمل مع وزاره النقل وزاره
النقل عملت خطوه
الزمت كل من يعمل يعني ما لديه عقد صيانه
تعرف يعني كان عندهم من اول 111 عقد الان
مع العقود الجديده صار 65 عقد يعني نوعي
همم انه لابد انه مهندس يعني يتدرب في
المركز وي- يدخل ياخذ همم الترخيص المهني
او الاعتماد المهني كم مهندس محترف همم
ان شاء الله مع الكون
هيكون واحد من المتطلبات انه المهندس
سلامه الطرق يجب ان يكون معتمد في عند
اعتماده سننتقل لمرحله ان يكون كل
المهندسه بالسلامه وعلى فكره ليس
المهندسين فقط حتى الممارسين يعني اليوم
حتى العامل اللي في منطقه عمل لابد كله
هندام معين نفور معين لا بدي كله واقفه
معينه لابد ان تحمي بطريقه معينه فاحنا
نحاول ان شاء الله من خلال الكود ومن خلال
العمل مع وزاره النقل انه باذن الله يكون
هناك تنظيم لمهنه سلامه الطرق وان يكون
احدى
المتطلبات هو الاعتماد المهني باذن الله
وعلى فكره المهندسه اللي ذكرتها هي اول
مهند سعوديه اللي هي المهندسه
ويعني همم يعني
من المتميزات
ومطوره لنموذج الاقتصادي في المركز وهي
اول مهندسه حصلت عليه وعندنا برضه المهندس
عمر همم يعني كبوش كان اول مهندس سعودي
حصل عليه بالنموذج الامريكي ما شاء الله
في الخليج
ااا الان عندنا ايضا مهندسين يعني ما
ابوذكر
اولويه المهندس الشعب السعودي انا بقول لك
حاجه انت لو ترجع لرؤيه المملكه وهذا
الجميع ترى اليوم انا اعتبر حاله من
الانفجار الابداع في الشباب في المملكه
يعني يعني هذه واحده من جوانب الرؤيه يمكن
ما ظهرت للناس كثير لاحظ الرؤيه عندما
حددت ثلاثه كامل
لقوه مكان القوه في المملكه ذكرت واحد من
المكان انه المملكه تسعى من خلال موقعها
الاستراتي تميز موقعها الاستراتيجي ان
تكون محرك للتجاره الدوليه
ورابط
القارات الثلاث اوروبا اسيا افريقيا طيب
هذا ما هو بكلام والناس والله جميله
لاول براجراف انا على ما اظنه اول برجراف
في الرؤيه تهدي في رؤيه المملكه 20 30 كذا
شوفي شو اللي مكتوب النص وتامل واقراه
بشكل
يعني تمكين الشباب
طاقاتهم وقدراتهم في التنميه
طيب كيف تطلع الطاقات والقدرات الى
التدريب والتاهيل بالتالي احنا في المركز
الرجاءنا لهذه النصوص المهمه في الرؤيه
وكانت هي النبراس لنا انها كيف نعكس
يعني نقلق الشباب وقدراتهم اليوم عندي 20
مهندس في المركز حصين على همم الاعراس به
اليوم عندي اكثر من 17 محققين فنيين انت
تعرف التحقيق الفني مو بانه بين يوم وليله
السيد محقق الان تبني مسار مهني منها لازم
تاخذ شهاده محترف سلامه الطرق جبنا هاليوم
المدرسه البريطانيه متقدمه في التحقيق
والمدرسه الامريكيه خبر في المركز
صار كل حادث يروحون يروح الخبير مع مجموعه
من المهندسين السعوديين ثلاث واربع كابل
يلاحظون يتعلمون يتدربون وعندهم القدره
اليوم الحمد لله بعد تجربتنا اليوم ااا
اكثر من 100 وتحادث حققنا فيهم لدي من
الشباب 17 مهندس ومهندسه
يستطيعون ان يقودون التحقيق ليش لانه من
اشتراطات ان تكون قائد فريق للتحقيق ان
تحقق يعني حسب كلام الخبراء لا يقل عن 15
حادث اليوم عندي من حقك في 20 22 حادث
بالاضافه الى حصولهم على 100 ساعه تدريب
في معهد فلوريد الامريكي اللي هو يعتبر في
العالم في التدريب على الحوادث فاحنا
اليوم استغلينا المركز في ان ندرب الشباب
نمكنهم
ونثق فيهم وعلى فكره يعني هي ثقافه بعض
الاحيان انا قلت لك انه الرؤيه اعطت
اعطتنا ثقافه القياس يعني ما في شيء ينهب
هزر والله والله وصلنا هنا لا الرؤيه تقول
لك مش مؤشرك
اليوم نعطيك احنا ننشي ثقافه من خلال
المركز مو فقط دعم فني ما ادري يمكن لو
يعني لا حطتهمش هذا انه مهندسي السلامه
عند الطرق بين فورم معين
يعني لا يمكن تقبل مهندس سعودي ينزل على
طريق بري يحقق في حوادث بالثوب الغتره
يعني نفتخر بنفسنا الوطني وكذا لكن ما هو
بعملي مثل الطبيب يدخل غرفه العمليات او
العسكري ببدل العسكريه احنا اليوم طلعنا
زي وزاره النقل تبنى هذا الموضوع نحاول
ننشرها الثقافه لانه اليوم مهما قدمت من
دعم تنظيمي تشريعي مالي اذا ما يكون عندك
القدرات البشريه فيها كفاءات وكوادر مؤهله
تاهيل عالي لا تستطيع ان تحقق النجاح 100%
من الاسئله
وتعليقاتهم في همم الدكتور خالد الدغيثر
عنده تغريد يقول تم الاتكاء على ساهر
وغاب تطبيق مواد نظام المرور ولائحه
التنفيذيه الميدانيه فغابت السلامه
المروريه اليوم في تصور عن كثيرين انه
الاداره العامه المرور صارت الاداره
العامه للكاميرات اكثر من انها اداره
المرور فقط كاميرات تزرع وغرامات
تنشر
ويعول على هذا الامر بانه هو اللي يحل
السلامه
ما في كاميرا هتتصرف باكثر تصرفات رعونه
وشفنا شوارع اليوم صارت يعني غابات صراحه
في في ذوق العام وفي طريقه القياده فش
رايك في دور المرور في موضوع السلامه
المروريه في الفتره الماضيه انا بقول لك
خلينا ناخذ عناصر في السلامه المروريه في
يعني عناصر مهمه كامل اليوم انا كممهندسه
وجيه هندسيه بصمم طريق
وشغله من تحت الصيانه لكن من اللي حيضبط
لي
الجهه الامنيه المرور
ما استطيع اني السائق هذا يخرج من منزل
دائما يقول البيوت لكم دور
اولادكم وبناتكم باهميه السلام المروريه
اربط حزام الامان
اليوم في بعض الممارسات انا بقول لك يعني
الحوادث بعض احيان تعلمك اشياء وبرجع لك
المرور بس اسمح لي
اليوم
تجد سياره
يعني واحده من المشاكل دائما نشوفها صراحه
في حوادث على الطرق البريه والله مؤلمه
وانا اقولها هنا لعل الجميع يعني يعني
يعني
يستفيد منها المعلومه
تجد سياره سعتها خمسه
لكن فيها ثمانيه ساعات
او ساعتها سبع فيها 12 او 11
طبعا نعرف انه في ظروف ناس وعوائل ما
تستطيع ولكن
الحمل هذه على السياره اي حادث
خصوص الاطفال استاذ عبد الله كل سلوك عند
الناس يضبط النظام يعني احترموا الناس
الحزام صح الا يوم صار المرور
في نصف الطريق بري
شو اسوي بالاسره هذه
تحاول تعطيها مخالفه هذا الدور الغائب
ليش الطفل هذا ما هو في كرسي اطفال اذا ما
في كاميرا لكرسي الاطفال عمره ما حد رجل
مروج وقفه
بالضبط
يعني وزاره الداخليه اليوم اذا ماتت كامل
مع الجهات الثانيه والجهات الثالث كامل
معها لن يكون هناك نجاح دور كبير همم
اليوم همم
اشكاليه كان طبعا تعرف انت لا يمكن تحط
رجل مرور في كل مكان
كم تقاطع في الرياض
لكن بتحتاج على الاقل رجل المرور في
المكان موجود اذا الناس تداولوا انه والله
اني طالع في الشارع
وانعطفت من اقصى اليسار الى اقصى اليمين
عشان الحق المخرج ممكن المرور
وسحاب من النقاط رخصتي اللي اذا تراك بشكل
معين رخصتي كلها تسحب كل اللي في
الاستراحه وكل اللي في المجلس يبيعون لكن
متى اخر مره سمعت في مجلس انه والله رجل
مرور وقف شخص
واعطاء مخالفه غير المعتاده قطع اشاره
سرعه حزام جوال وهذه مو بالان رجل المرور
انتبه لها لان في كاميرا صورت فاليوم صارت
الكاميرا هي اللي تحرك المرور وليس رجل
المرور هذا اللي يخشون الناس نعم انا اقول
لك شوف الكاميرات اليوم انتشرت طبعا تعريف
وجود رجال المرور لكن مثل ما ذكرته لك انا
يعني
التوسع اللي صاير في المدن ضخامه همم
يعني في وجود تواجد قد يكون يحتاج دعم
اكبر يعني حتى يقع لكنه الاشكاليه انه
المرور ليست ضبط المروري بمفرد يعني اليوم
انت داخل المدن نجم
يعني جانب من العمل صراحه بس اليوم يعني
لو بسالكم عبد الله في ناس يقولون الحل
يبدا من مدارس تعليم القياده صحيح مفترض
انه هذول يعني ما يخرجون الشخص ويعطونا
رخصته الا وهو عنده كل هذه
المتطلبات وفي ناس يقولوا لا مهما علمته
في مدرسه القياده اذا طلع في الغابه
بيتحول الى عنصر من الغابه لازم المرور
يطبق الانظمه بحزم داخل المدن عشان الناس
بتعلمون بالهارد واي حتى لو ما تعلمنا من
المدرسه يعني انت وين ترى البدايه الاهم
تكلم مهمه
[موسيقى]
اسرع التوعيه همم ما احد يسمع منك كثير
وحتى انا الغي دوت الواعي لكن هذا يحتاج
لك يمكن تعمل عليها
النظام في البيئه غير المحترمه يجد نفسه
في في المسار الصحيح اذا بلاقي سبع
يتجاوزون
ويقفون في المسار الخاطئ ويدخلون قبلي انا
معناته كده قاعد اقول للصحيح الملتزم تراك
انت الخسران راح خالف زيهم عشان لا تشعر
عليك الانوار وانت ماشي حتى في امان الله
يكبس عليه
سياره قدام السياره
في السماء
13 13 سبعه
لا يعني احنا نفرح انه صار الحمد لله
عندنا يعني معناته عدد الثقه في انفسنا ان
الجهود ممكن تثمر ولكن ترى مازلنا رجل
يعني تتكلم اليوم انا وانت في حلقاتنا
يعني ممكن ساعه ونصف ناخذ سعر اربع ضحايا
ما تبقى واحد ووفات وثلاثه مصابين اصابه
جسيمه يعني
لكن احنا
لابد انه لا يشكر الناس لا شكر الله وبرضه
عشان نحفز نفوسنا
اليوم انت اخذت الرقم من تسعه الاف وفاه
الى اربعه الاف شوي هتعمل جبار على فكره
حتى منظمه الصحه العالميه دبليو اتش اوه
قالت انه 40% تخفيض في المؤشر وفيات لكل
100,000 في المملكه العربيه السعوديه على
طريق هذا المؤشر ابو عبد الله يعني اللي
هو المصدر رسمي الحكومي ذكر فارس التركي
قد نزل السنابات يقول انه البنك الدولي
ينشر ارقام مختلفه يعني ارقام الداخليه
تذكر فرق هذا
صحيه الان من خلال الوزاريه يعني شوف كانت
هيئه الاحصاء وكانت المصادر المختلفه
اليوم تحت اللجنه الوزاريه للسلام
المروريه اصبح جهه هي تتواصل مع
الجهات الدوليه حتى يكون المصدر واحد في
اليوم
الاخير غير تقرير ها السابق يعني كم مشوش
يعني البنك الدولي او اليونسكو
بحياتها تطلع ارقام الان لا مع وجود
اللجنه وزاريه اصبح هذا الرقم واحد وتاكد
لكن على فكره
4,500 تخيلي يموتون سنه يعني سنه 20 21 في
المملكه بقدر ما نفرح بان نجحنا في 6 4000
صحيح ابدا لذلك العالم متجه للفجر زيرو او
الرؤيه الصفريه يعني اليوم بدت هولندا
السويد استراليا وطلعوا بنظام السلامه
الامن
المملكه الحمد الله وقعت هذا الامر العام
الماضي او قبل العام في السويد كان مع
الوزير النقل يعني حاضر
في ستوكم السويد واعلن اعلان السويد
والجزمنا فيه في المملكه الان التزام انه
في عام 20 30 يخفض 50% من الوفيات
المروريه في السعوديه اي ولكن الاهم من
هذا انه التزمنا بتبني السيف الابراج اللي
هو نظام السلامه او نظام الامن الشمولي
ايش معناته من اول كنا نقول الحادث السائق
يا اخي هو المسؤول يلا خلاص
وتعرف احنا عاده يعني ترى على فكره في
جميع دول العالم
لو تروح حتى في امريكا ولا كل اللي بيدافع
عن شغله يقول انا بالطرق لا طرق ممتازه
السيارات مواصفاتها ممتازه انا قاعد اضبط
الشارع في كل واحد يدافع انا نقلت في
الوقت المناسب
المصاب اليوم
النظام الامن يقول كلنا شير على الطاوله
نتشارك في المسؤوليه انا اعتقد هذا
التغيير في الدهنيه مهم جدا لتغيير
المشكله اليوم حقيقه يجب ان لا نفرح حتى
لو واحد يموت
يجب ان نستمر وان شاء الله الرقم هذا يقل
ثمن يقل اليوم المملكه تستهدف انها تكون
حسب الرؤيه اقل من زمان وفيات يكون 100
الف نسمه
انا متفائل ربما نصل الى يعني اذا الجهود
بهذا الرتم بهذا الزخم ربما نحقق لكن ترى
على فكره السلوك المروري كمشهد ما تغير
عندنا في المملكه
وعلى فكره يعني قررت على فكره كثير لكنهم
ذكرته في شيء مفهوم
السلامه الامن اولا يجب ان لا يكون
الخطا البشري يقود الانسان الى ان يفقد
حياته
يجب ان يكون
المتسامحه يعني في يعني طلعت من برا الخط
اذا في عمود كهرب الجهه المالكي طريق حطت
حول اسفنج ولا ماصد صدم تمام يعني قلت اسف
للفم ممكن اصدم بالعمود مباشره او اصدم هل
ماصه الصدم يختلف الحادث باذن الله تعالى
همم السرعه برضو اذا جبت ساهر وخليت
السرعه اقل سؤال كان له مساهمه في
الانخفاض اللي صار طبعا
الرصد الالي
الحيه ما في دراسه حتى الان كما ولكن
الرصد الالي في مواقع اعطيك مثال كان هناك
تقاطعات في مدن المملكه غير محكومه محكومه
بالاشاره الضوئيه ولايه يوجد فيها ساهر
كانت الحوادث فيها مميته يعني ما هي مره
اسبوع الا فيه وفاه
بعد الكاميرات في التقاطعات الضوئيه
بالذات
اقول لك صار الصفر النتيجه في بعض التقاطع
ابنها في سؤال هنا على موضوع الدورات
التدريب بيقولوا ليش كلها تغطيه مدينه
الرياض فقط انتم الظاهر عندكم بس احنا
بالعكس الاسبوع
ال 500 مهندس سعودي
تستطيع ان تسجل في المنصه وصلت المعلومه
وين التدريب بيكون والماده التدريبيه
الحقيبه التدريبيه تجدها بدون مقابل
هذا المهتمين بالسلامه المروريه انه احنا
نقدم برنامج اسمه وقت الاستشاره مجاني اذا
اي مهندس في اي مكان في المملكه عندك
مشكله في تقاطع في طريق
وعندك حلول بس ما وصلت الى الحل ارسل لنا
الموقع بالصور بسيطه تواصل معنا من خلال
المركز الوطني هذا البرنامج دشنا معالي
وزير النقل
يعني الاشهر
ومستعدي لتقديم يعني خبره نوعيه ومساعده
واستشاره مجانيه لك في هذا جزاك الله خير
انا بدي اختم ابو عبد الله بسؤال يعني
يكون هو مبني على استفسار هنا على موضوع
الجوال همم ودي احاول الى توجيه ويعني
نصيحه منك بحكم اللي شاهدته همم وبحكم
الخبره لو اليوم في شباب وبنات اسمعوا لنا
ممكن همم ننقذ ارواح
توصيه او نصيحه فيما يخص سلوكهم هم احنا
ناقشنا الحلقه كلها على دور الجهات
التنفيذيه اليوم نتكلم على دور الفرد
نفسها وايش اهم نصيحه بتقول لها
لهل الشباب والبنات على ننقذ بعض الارواح
بحاول لا تسرع
لانك
اذا انت ماشي بالطريق وماشي منيح او 80
كيلو متر في الساعه
بس عشان تقف لو في امامك تحتاج يمكن حوالي
40 متر مهما عملت ليش لانك انت تفكر ايش
القرار اللي تاخذه تضرب تحط رجلك على
الدواسر الفرامل هذه بتاخذ منك الثانيه
الثانيه والسياره ماشيه 80 ترى يمكن حوالي
30 الى 40 متر
السرعه امم الحوادث وام مهالك المرور
المرور
حاول لانه
كل ما حفظت سرعه كلما اعطاك مجال بالاضافه
من ناحيه فيزيائيه ليش انت تسبح بعض
الاحيان انه تقطعوا اللي في الحادث
بتر
ما وجدنا راسه
يعني ما ودي اقول الكلام هذا لانه مؤلم
والله
لكن الناس يعني كنا نروح نشوف الحوادث
نحصل عظام
احيانا بنحصل الاجزاء البشريه ليش لانه
قوه الصدمه هذه تنتج طاقه
الطاقه هذه عباره عن قوه فوق احتمال جسم
الانسان كلما زادت السرعه كلما كانت فوق
احتمال جسمك مهما كنت مشكله الشباب اننا
لاحظت انه يعتقد انه في السياره وهو في
دبابه
مغلق درع ما يقدر احد يقربه والله اقول
لهم حادث واحد ممكن يسبب لك شلل لقدر الله
ولك روح مستشفى المجمع الملك سعود الطبي
في الرياض وادخل عند شباب في سن الزهور 18
19 20 كان ما كنت اتوقع اني بوصل للحاله
هذه هذا معظم تفكير الشباب يسرع ينطلق
يعتقد انه محصل حادث واحد ممكن يقضي عليك
انتبه الشيء الثاني اللي جوه
انا انا ذكرت انه وانت ماشي 80 بس 80 ممكن
يفيد يعني تقطع في الثانيه حوالي
يعني 30 40 متر
انت لو تسوي تاكستينج مع الاسف تشوف
الكثير من الناس مسج او رسائل جوال
يعني ممكن السياره اللي قدامك او يكون
ماشي او طفل ما تنتبه له كثير ما امداني
قفل الجوال ارجوك انا اقول له كل شاب
هل يحبونك
وراكم ام اب اصدقاء اخوان اخوات
انتبه من السرعه ومن الجوال ترى اذا
انتبهت من هالشين باذن الله باذن الله لن
يصيبك شيء لا تحول رحله انك تطلب رزقك من
البيت الى مكان عملك قد هذه الرحله ما
تعود فيها للبيت الله يجزاك خير
همم ابن عم الوالد رجل كبير وحكيم وكان
شوف ياثر يعني لما يروح المزرعه عند
الوالده يكون المسرع والطريق تقريبا 70
كيلو الواحد يظن انه طبعا
160 170
فمره همم ناداني قال لي همم
والله مستعجلين بالحق قال ابي اطلب منك
طلب 120
استجابه لطلبك بس عشان يوريك الفرق هذا
ابشر لما وصلت الرياض كلمته قال كم الفرق
المده قلت له سته دقائق
على مستوى حياتك مقابل فرق 6 الى 10 دقائق
موعد الوصول هذا ما يسوى ابدا المخاط
الواحد ياخذها فتغير نظرتي تماما عن
السرعه بعد نصيحه هذا العام
يا شباب
يعني تكون شاحنه امامك في جزء من الثاني
ان تخرج من مسارك تدخل في الشاحن هذه
حوادث
كثير عوائل واطفال اذا مو ضحيه سائق يعني
ليش تستخدم الجوال لا تنتهي لا تنتهي
بعدين انا اطلب من الناس اللي في المناطق
احنا تعرف عندنا عادات اجتماعيه احيانا
والله جميله وجديده وحنه شعر كريم ونحب
بعضنا لكن اخي اذا انت في مدينه بعيده
وعندك زواج لا تجبر
قريبك وصديقك ياتي بالسياره لاني والله
رايت حوادث كثيره
رايحين المناسبات اجتماعيه
يا اخي لا تكلفون على بعضكم
ويتحول هذا الزواج الى ماتم يعني
وتتحول المناسبه الفرح الى الى ترح الله
بالتوفيق في
توفير طرق رحيمه متسامحه وفي تخفيض 13 الى
ثمانيه واقل بدنا تعالى في 20 مركز سر
مركز
جميعا شكرا
لكم
الكاميرات وفي تسجيل الصوت وفي التحرير
محمد الديني وفي الهندسه الصوتيه محمد
الحسن وفي الاشراف على الانتاج رزان
سكران احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه
[موسيقى]